okay let's um
on to the final Talk of the meet the
fellows event so we'll have Alex
Lombardi who will see that he slightly
changed the title but he will talk about
Quantum advantage and non-local games
hey everyone thanks for coming uh so
yeah I'll be talking to the the
technical meet of what I talk about
anyway it will be based on a joint work
with the alkaline my advisor is welcome
to nothing and we see ya
um since this is the meet the fellows
event let me give a quick self
introduction first uh so I am a postdoc
here for this year I finished my PhD uh
at MIT uh in the fall
and while I'm very broadly interested in
basically anything vaguely related to
cryptography and anything daily related
to the theory of computation
um a lot of what I've worked on over the
last I don't know five years uh has been
focused on this area uh that I like to
informally call cryptographic proofs uh
so I'm not going to Define this very
carefully but basically I'm talking
about uh questions in a computational
model where you have two parties
approver and a verifier
and the prover wants to convince the
verifier of some piece of information
and I'll leave it to that vaguely
because there are different ways of like
instantiating this uh this kind of
question uh and so why do I seem to keep
working in this area why why do I uh
like it so much uh well it allows you to
combine three really powerful and really
flexible computational resources into
one place uh so the first of these is
interaction we allow the too far parties
to uh communicate with each other back
and forth uh the second is Randomness or
depending on the setting maybe even
Quantum information so what does that
mean it means that I can send you not
just a message but maybe a message from
a distribution or I can have an internal
Quantum State and measure my states to
determine what message to send to you
things like this
and then finally uh the third resource
is computational hardness and by that I
mean that's uh in in these protocols
we're often happy even if uh you know
certain certain guarantees of this
protocol only hold against
computationally bounded parties the the
recruiter or the verifier we assume is
computationally founded and then we
prove something must happen uh and when
you combine all these three things
together you get basically magic just
like some ridiculous stuff happens uh
and I'm very interested in trying to
understand precisely what kinds of magic
you can and cannot do
um so this this model has been really
influential in both Theory and in
Practical cryptography although I assume
this is mostly a theory audience but
like you know from from like the
theoretical end of just like general
purpose secure multi-party computation
to like on the very practical end of
like our like current systems for
authentication on the internets and our
post and also like post-modern
applications like blockchain and
cryptocurrencies you know proof systems
are sort of a foundation underlying all
of this stuff
uh and then the area also seems to have
a great track record in its interactions
with other areas of theoretical computer
science insights about proof systems
have turned out to tell us a lot of
things in the realm of complexity Theory
whether it's about about you know
directly about interactive proofs how
they characterize peace based
computation these things went on to
influence uh questions not obviously
about interactive proofs like the PCP
theorem uh in Game Theory we've recently
come up with you know characterizations
of the hardness of finding Nash
equilibria uh in terms of you know based
on or we've proven that that such
problems are hard assuming cryptographic
assumptions going through proof systems
and also recently we've seen that the
improved systems have a lot to say about
the nature of quantum computation and
demonstrating uh demonstrating that you
have a quantum computer or just proving
that you've done a certain kind of
quantum computation so this this last
thing or something in this uh in this
last regime is what I'm actually going
to focus on uh for this talk so today
we're going to just talk about how you
could possibly prove that you are
quantum and so so what do I mean by this
roughly speaking I mean suppose you have
a Quantum device
suppose that's uh you know you want to
convince somebody who does not have a
Quantum device that you have a Quantum
device and so since I don't have a
Quantum device you are limited to
interacting with them complete
classically you can only send them
classical messages but you want them to
believe somehow that you have a
quantities
uh so how do you do that uh so there are
a couple of things you could do
one is what I would call like the like
the very direct approach of just like uh
so here's something you can do uh the
classical for now and I'll call them the
verifier the classical verifier can send
me the description of an NP problem
uh say an NP search problem and they can
ask me
you know to give them an influence uh
and if this NP search problem is also in
bqp in in Quantum polynomial time and I
have a at least a Quantum polynomial
time computer uh then I can find this
witness and then I can hand it to them
they can verify the NP relation and
we're done uh and so uh so fat so
solving like a factoring or discrete
logarithm type problem would exactly
allow you to do this uh
also due to a recent breakthrough uh
last year by Yama Collins Andrew we
actually know that this this kind of
quantum Advantage actually exists
relative to a random Oracle which is
pretty amazing
uh so this is what I would call the
direct approach but so what I what I
want to emphasize right now about this
direct approach is that in order to do
this you are essentially assuming away
the problem in some sense that is you're
you're just literally assuming that
there is a that there is a computational
problem that cannot be solved in
classical polynomial time that can be
solved in Quantum polynomial time uh and
there's no way around it if this is your
this is your approach uh
so now let me talk about a second option
this is introduced in a really uh
interesting work of broccoli Cristiano
mahada bazarani and vidic a few years
ago they introduced like what is now
called an interactive proof of
quantumness and it's basically you know
it's a similar idea except now we allow
the prover and the verifier to interrupt
they execute an interactive protocol at
the end the we like we with the quantum
device would like to verify or to accept
and we want a protocol where no at least
no efficient classical device can make
the verifier except with a similar
probability
uh and so something that I find really
interesting about this object is that
you can possibly have them like without
knowing whether or not bqp is equal to P
which sounds kind of ridiculous if we
started with how do I prove that I have
it but I'm doing efficient Quantum
computation and now I'm saying we don't
even need to assume P naught equal bqp
but this is you know something
ridiculous that the interactive model
throws at us
um and in very few words like
how is this possible like how how could
you
how how do how do you separate efficient
Quantum and classical computation
without assuming a hard problem a
classically hard problem that's
quantumly easy somehow you separate
these two models uh by thinking about
rewinding so an interesting thing in the
interactive model is that you can sort
of analyze what's going on by imagining
that you run a party forwards through
the protocol and then try to go back in
time and see what they would say if you
sent them a different message like in
the middle of the protocol execution or
something like that and this is
something that you can easily talk about
if the party is classical because you
can save their states and then just you
know tell them to resume from an earlier
point in time but with a Quantum device
this might be inherently impossible due
to no cloning type issues or or another
way to put it is that like in order to
get their message at some point in time
they may have measured their state in a
destructive way that is not reversible
and that's how you can separate these
two models uh so in this paper that I
mentioned at the beginning of the talk
we give a new family of interactive
proofs of quantumness by making a very
direct connection to this thing called
Quantum non-locality and I will just
show this to you by example so let me
just I'll I'll give you an extremely
simple protocol for improving
quantumness here's here's how it works
the verifier picks a random bit X so X
is a x is one bit
it encrypts the bit with some encryption
scheme I haven't said anything about it
yet and sends the ciphertext to the
proverb that's what happened so far and
the verifier in this protocol expects
the prover to send back some ciphertext
for this encryption scheme whatever the
pre percent of the verifier will
interpret it as a cycle text
uh next the verifier sample is an
independent second bit why and sends
this bit to the prover and the prover
responds with some bit B so we've got
we've got four bits that we care about
so we have X we have a which I'll call
the decryption of whatever the proofer
sent and then Y and V X and Y are
sampled IID but the verifier incentive
approver in this way and the approval
response somehow and the verifier
accepts in this protocol if uh if a
linear condition is satisfied between A
and B the two bits that the prover is
effectively communicating uh yes you
check that uh that the sum of A and B is
equal to the end of the two bits that
the verifier sampled and note that the
proverb does not know what x is that I
mean it has an encryption of X but it
doesn't know what x is so it doesn't
exactly know what condition the verifier
is checking but there's a protocol that
you can run uh and we prove that if the
encryption scheme is appropriately
homomorphic if you can sort of evaluate
some gates uh on a ciphertext
then there is an efficient Quantum
device here or an efficient Quantum
algorithm for the proverb that does
better than what any efficient classical
algorithm can do provably uh yeah
assuming that the encryption is uh
secure
this is what we show so it's an
extremely simple protocol and if you've
seen anything like this before you
should you should you know this should
probably remind you of something so this
is this is directly inspired from uh
from a proof system in a different
computational model uh so this this uh
so this thing that I've written on the
slide is called the chsh game it's a
game between uh verifier and two
proverbers
uh where so this is an information
theoretic model so the proofers are
unbounded but we assume they can't
communicate with each other
uh and and the chsh game is a is a proof
system in this model which it looks
almost exactly like what I just told you
the only difference now is that
each of the provers gets one of the bits
from the verifier and they're supposed
to respond to those bits separately
uh and so yeah so this this model has
been studied for a long time in Quantum
information Theory and I mean even even
in non-quantum settings also there's
nothing inherently Quantum about this
model uh but so the point is that if the
two provers in this game are allowed to
share some entanglement it turns out
that they can beat any classical
quote-unquote strategy so and I I won't
show you how this works but it turns out
that if the two-provers share an epr
pair they can make the verifier accept
the probability about 85 percent
but also if they don't share
entanglements they can't beat 0.75 in
this game
uh and
and the the analysis for this for this
fact is like two lines so I'll just show
it to you as a reminder so let's see why
you can't beat 75 classically well if
the two proofers are classical then
essentially four bits describe the
strategy just what their answers are to
each of the possible two questions that
they get sent so we'll call those four
numbers a0 A1 b0 and B1 and the claim is
simply that you can't get the there like
at most three of the four things that
you want to be true can be true and so
here I mean it's I'm sure any of you
could prove this in about two minutes
but like but let me show you one
particular way of of driving this so
here are the two equations for uh fixed
prover one question X and for the two
questions sent to proverb two b equals
zero and b equals one
so if the approvers are right on X comma
zero you know that ax plus B zero is
zero and if they're right on X comma one
then ax plus B1 is equal to X
but if they're right on both of these
and you can combine the two equations
and get that B zero plus B1 is equal to
X
however excess sampled uniformly at
random independent of the view of quiver
2. and these are on V1 are just if just
depend on proof or two
and so this this derived condition can
only happen with probability a half
and so you get that overall you can only
do 0.75 well
so this is the information theoretic
analysis
and now I'll show you that we proved
essentially the same thing for this
interactive mean
so what's the what are the let me just
point to like the key differences from
the previous setting
so in the previous setting we used the
facts that uh or in or at least the
model you know explicitly states that
sort of the two previous are independent
of each other right
so here sort of the prover one is
certainly like indep like can't depend
on prove or two right because prover 2
literally happens afterwards
however prover 2 can depend on proof or
one and that's the difference right
however
proverb 2 doesn't really know what
prover1 did
because the question was encrypted and
that's why there's some hope of this
being reasonable and indeed what we're
going to show is that if the prover
cannot break the encryption scheme then
you can't beat 0.75 in this in this
computational game
uh and the yeah so the proof is is very
similar so
if the prover is classical we can
describe it with three functions
uh
there's the function which determines
the second message based on the first
message
and then there are two functions that
determines the the final bits the prover
sends depending on whether y equals zero
or y equals one is sent
okay
and so we claim that you can't beat 0.75
and the reason is well let's so let's
think about this fixed prover strategy
and uh and let's fix and let's fix the
first message in the protocol
and then let's suppose for a second that
the approver were writes on both the Y
equals zero and Y equals one questions
then we get these two conditions so uh
so this a sub X hat I'm defining to be
just the decryption of the of a hat and
yeah so if the prover is right on zero
and one we get these two constraints
but if these are both correct then we
again get that b0 and B1 these are
functions of X hats uh that they xor to
uh to X the same as before
so
in other words so if the prover answers
both questions correctly then this V 0
plus V1 piece of information predicts
the encrypted bit X only given the
ciphertext X hat
but that shouldn't be possible
everything that this is an efficient
reduction the encryption scheme is
secure then there's nothing that we
should be able to write down that
actually predicts access probability
better than a half and so you get that
you can't yeah so if you did better than
0.75 you would predict the encrypted bit
with probability better than a half and
so you can't and so this is a
computational you know analog of the of
the lower bound on the chsh game against
local strategies
uh and now the punch line is that this
is completely General uh that that was
that was a special case but you can
actually show that for any non-local
game uh
there's this we have this General
compiler which does exactly what you
just saw that like turns proverb one
into like an encrypted strategy and then
turns proverb or two into a strategy in
the clear that happens after the fact
and we show that you know if the
encryption scheme is homorphic enough
then uh first of all you can emulate any
entangled strategy on a single device
with a single prover
meanwhile if the encryption scheme is
secure then a classical device can't
beat that like in the
interactive game can do no better than a
local strategy in this uh two-prover
game and so you can inherit any
like entangled versus unentangled Gap uh
into a Quantum versus classical Gap in
the interactive setting in the
computationally bounded interactive
setting there are a bunch of a bunch of
questions that I'd love to understand
better like in this in this regime like
uh like uh for example if if you care
about only you know specific you know
constant sized games the amount of
homomorphism you need here is very small
and so I'd hoped for results of
something of the form like you can do
this based on any post Quantum one-way
function or something like that that
would be a very nice results
um there are more practical aspects
Wonder like of like uh maybe you can get
like a really efficient uh you know
Quantum Quantum strategy here if you
choose things very carefully and finally
uh like the quantum value of this
interactive game understanding it in
general is still wide open like there's
some ongoing work where we can
understand in some very special cases
but uh but but in most cases we really
have we don't really know how to talk
about the quantum value of this game
it's related to questions about
rewinding Quantum devices
uh and uh and yeah so I yeah I also like
this question because of this complexity
theoretic implication of like you don't
even need to assume P naught equal to
bqp uh in order to uh in order to uh
possibly have it I also it's also not
known whether you need P does not equal
NP for this thing so basic so I think
essentially all that's known about the
complexity of interactive proofs of
quantiness is that you need to assume P
naught equal to P space because you can
compute the optimal proverb strategy in
t-space and I think that's basically all
that's known and I'd love to understand
better like what the complexity
theoretic implications of this kind of
object is
uh so that's all thank you
a little over time but maybe we can take
a question to round off the program
let's see
um I think just like I I mean I think
just Computing a message that would make
the verifier except will be an NP
intersect pqp search Problem
foreign
so I'm not sure how much I followed but
you mentioned that you don't want to
assume away the problem
um but I guess I was wondering
if you show the proof of quantum this
from any other assumption how do you why
are you not interpreting not as evidence
of a separation ah because uh you can do
this assuming the hardness of learning
with errors
right and and it's believed that
learning with errors is quantumly hard
like the assumption is is potentially
agnostic to whether or not the adversary
is quantum or classical
yeah so
oh it's sorry the reason is that there's
the proof of security sort of
distinguishes like that the way that you
Analyze This distinguishes Quantum and
classical devices in a way that doesn't
require making an assumption like like
the so the proof that I did or maybe
maybe I went over it too fast but like
what I said here was that a classical
device can't win here because it would
be able to predict X if I ran it twice
right I I ran it twice to get this v0
and B1 and then I said well I can get X
by running down the sum at least I could
predict that predict X I write down the
sum
but if the Brewer is quantum then the
second time that you run it there's no
guarantee that uh even if it was
successful originally that it would it
would send you a valid answer later and
so so the the proof is is actually
separating the models the Assumption
doesn't have to
yeah let's maybe take further questions
offline
um let's thank all the speakers
[Applause]
thanks to all of course for coming
um and we have a light lunch